depuis quelques temps des rumeurs
circuler et dans les milieux bien
informés sur l'éventualité d'un
remaniement ministériel qui rigoureux
ils nous appellent en direct de l'elysée
thierry oui bernard pour la première
fois dans l'histoire de la vème
république
les téléspectateurs vont pouvoir vivre
en direct un remaniement ministériel le
président a décidé d'autoriser les
journalistes à assister à un événement
que ses prédécesseurs avaient toujours
entourée du plus grand secret mais voici
les ministres qui pénètre dans le salon
on aperçoit monsieur du bougès le
ministre de l'économie
monsieur fado le ministre des armées
mademoiselle du flon de l'agriculture
ils forment un cercle en se tenant par
la main
il s'assoit maintenant sur le tapis de
savonnerie tapis offert je le rappelle
au passage en 1904 au président loubet
par sa belle-mère
les visages sont tendus l'instant est
solennel
le président se lève il agite sa
pochette
il se met à faire le tour du cercle en
marchant de plus en plus vite
il se met à courir ou plutôt un à
trotter et il aa il a laissé tomber un
mouchoir derrière le ministre de la
communication qui ne s'est pas laissé
prendre au piège et qui de son côté
commence à tourner autour du cercle
qu'est ce qui va se passer on ne le sait
pas dans quelques instants on va
peut-être le savoir et à huy très très
habilement le ministre de la
communication a laissé choir le mouchoir
derrière le ministre de la santé qui n'a
encore rien vu le ministre de la
communication eux continuent à la même
allure c'est tout à fait extraordinaire
elle sera chargée d'électricité
maintenant des communes sa communication
la criée
c'est extraordinaire vous le voyez le
ministre de la santé gagne maintenant le
centre du ser tandis que la ministre de
la communication qui a repris le
mouchoir continue à tourner autour du
cercle qui sera la prochaine victime je
ne sais pas assez le ministre de
l'agriculture qui vient de réagir
promptement à pied s'est emparé de
booster et c'est justement ce 5 août à
courir elle va courir sur kim batten
lancé le mousseur je ne sais pas où tu
as peut-être là voilà elle marc ottomani
question mais je de ses travaux elle a
hésité un instant leur part elle
s'arrête pas elle fait semblant de ce
dès le 12 mars et koutat fixe en venir
c'est une famille et les merveilleuses
et s'étend elle a recommencé ça fait
produire un effet coup thierry je dois
vous reprendre l'antenne
thierry oui merci de nous avoir fait
vivre en direct cet événement risque de
durer encore très longtemps je vous
rappellerai dans le journal de 23
seraient en mesure de vous communiquer
les noms de ceux qui auraient été
éliminés
ministre de la santé vient d'être
chandelle pour la deuxième fois
je crains que ce soit fini pour lui
d'ailleurs vous le voyez qui people le
cercle sous les huit de ses collègues un
gouverneur à vous les studios